Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The English people are being betrayed. Under the influence of dangerous new foreign ideas, a tiny minority of metropolitan intellectuals are trying to undermine our national history and destroy our traditional culture. Never before has our identity been...
感谢收听《历史余温》。想要获取每周的额外剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。英国人民正遭到背叛。在危险的新外来思想影响下，一小撮大都市知识分子正试图破坏我们的国家历史，摧毁我们的传统文化。我们的身份认同从未像现在这样……
You get the gist. So this is England in the 1530s, it's England in the 1640s,land in the 1700s the 1900s the 1960s and now once again in the 2020s welcome to the rest is history with battle scarred culture warrior tom holland and me the far more nuanced and reasonable dominic sam brooke dominic hello you are so battle-scarred in the culture wars. I mean, you write for the Daily Mail. That's the essence of a culture warrior. Okay, you're going to go there straight away.
你明白我的意思了。所以这就是1530年代的英国，1640年代的英国，1700年代、1900年代、1960年代的英国，以及现在2020年代的英国。欢迎收听《历史余温》，我是伤痕累累的文化斗士汤姆·霍兰，还有我，那位更加细腻、理性的多米尼克·桑布鲁克。多米尼克，你好，你在文化战争中真是伤痕累累啊。我的意思是，你为《每日邮报》撰稿。那可是文化斗士的精髓。好吧，你直接就切入正题了。
Fair enough. Now I know where we stand. I'm hacking you down early. We are going to get into the history of culture wars. Maybe we'll fight some culture wars in the second half of the pod but maybe the start with i think it's really this is such a hot topic and i think we should really sort of get into what culture wars are are they confected you know where do they come from historically and we might as well start i think
说得好。现在我知道我们的立场了。我一开始就得反驳你。我们要深入探讨文化战争的历史。也许我们在播客的后半部分会打几场文化战争，但我想我们还是先从这里开始吧，这是一个非常热门的话题，我认为我们真的应该深入探讨一下什么是文化战争，它们是人为制造的吗？你知道它们在历史上是从哪里来的？我想我们不妨从这里开始。
tom with a question so we've got a question from gilberto more back who says what is the first instance of a cultural he says it's not the culture camp which is bismarck's war against the catholic church itself now i don't think it is i think culture wars are as old as history itself and i think they go back to you know what are the greeks and the persians but a culture war what are the arguments within the roman republic but a culture war but maybe tom you disagree i do disagree because i think that if you use culture war to mean the war between two different cultures i mean every that's every war every war is is bringing different perspectives different cultural understandings different cultural assumptions so you might just as well say war i think i think but that's not that's not
汤姆，有个问题。我们收到吉尔伯托·莫雷巴克的问题，他问文化战争的第一个例子是什么。他说那不是俾斯麦针对天主教会的“文化斗争”（Kulturkampf）。现在，我不认为那是第一个例子。我认为文化战争和历史一样古老。我认为它们可以追溯到……你知道，希腊人和波斯人之间难道不是一场文化战争吗？罗马共和国内部的争论难道不是文化战争吗？但也许汤姆你不同意。我确实不同意，因为我认为如果你用“文化战争”来指代两种不同文化之间的战争，那么每一场战争都是如此。每一场战争都在引入不同的视角、不同的文化理解、不同的文化假设，所以你大可以干脆说“战争”。我认为……但我认为那不是……
quite but the idea of um that's not really what I mean. What I mean is the argument about who should we be? What are our values? What's our identity? I mean, Greeks did argue about those things. And Romans argued about them and said, you know, are we becoming too Greek? Are we becoming too Persian? Are we betraying our ancestors? Are we living up to our history?
那并不是我真正想表达的意思。我的意思是关于“我们应该成为什么样的人？”的争论。我们的价值观是什么？我们的身份是什么？我的意思是，希腊人确实争论过这些事情。罗马人也争论过，他们会说：“我们是不是变得太希腊化了？我们是不是变得太波斯化了？我们是否背叛了祖先？我们是否辜负了我们的历史？”
All those arguments, which we have as britons right now or americans they are as old as history itself but you see i think that's like saying that julius caesar conquered france it it's kind of true but it's also missing quite a lot and i think it risks anachronism so i i do think that that the culture camp you know it begins with yeah basically it does begin with with bismarck and the oh i don't agree the conflict with with the with with the catholic church as a concept as a category and perhaps you can then back project that in a certain way but i think that that essentially the the culture war that bismarck is engaged in is over the the limits of um religious authority over a secularizing state so i think it's about
所有这些争论，我们作为英国人或美国人现在也在进行，它们和历史一样古老。但你看，我觉得这就像说“尤利乌斯·凯撒征服了法国”一样，这在某种程度上是真的，但它也遗漏了很多东西，而且我认为这有时代错误的风险。所以我确实认为，“文化斗争”基本上是从俾斯麦和……哦，我不同意。与天主教会的冲突作为一个概念、一个类别，也许你可以以某种方式将其投射回去，但我认为俾斯麦所参与的文化战争本质上是关于宗教权威对世俗化国家的限制。所以我认为这是关于……
the tensions between the secular and the self-professingly christian but an astonishing surprise yeah but as you as you will know of course the the concept of the secular is itself a christian one so what i would say a culture war is basically it's sublimated theology so it it it is generated out of out of a specifically christian context but it's a a context in which one side no longer recognizes itself as being christian so it's a kind of post-christian war so that's i think so i think that all the culture wars in america they are essentially all revolving around issues of christian theology it's just that one side doesn't recognize that and once i don't let's go back for tom i want to go back further
世俗与自称基督教之间的紧张关系。令人惊讶的是，是的，但正如你所知，世俗的概念本身就是基督教的概念。所以我认为文化战争基本上是升华了的神学，它产生于一个特定的基督教背景，但在这个背景下，其中一方不再承认自己是基督教的，所以这是一种后基督教时代的战争。所以我认为美国所有的文化战争本质上都围绕着基督教神学问题，只是其中一方不承认这一点。让我们回到……汤姆，我想追溯得更远一点。
before let's before we get back to bismarck and christianity and stuff are you saying that when in in the sort of the later days of the roman republic which you've written about you know so successfully um when people are arguing that the the founding ideals the sort of puritan what they see is the puritanical ideals of the republic have been lost and they are arguing about um what they see is the luxurious effeminacy and decadence of the modern age and you know people like cato are arguing against what they see as the sort of the new people who are un-roman and all that stuff you don't think there's a culture war element to that you really don't i think it's more about political style because that's the essence but that's what culture wars are about i'm not sure it is because i think that it's it's about i think that bake it
在回到俾斯麦和基督教之前，你是说在罗马共和国后期——你对此写过非常成功的文章——当人们争论共和国的建国理想（他们所认为的清教徒式理想）已经丧失时，当他们争论现代社会的奢靡、柔弱和颓废时，当像加图这样的人反对那些他们认为“非罗马”的新人时，你不认为其中有文化战争的成分吗？你真的不认为吗？我认为这更多是关于政治风格，因为那是本质。但那正是文化战争的本质。我不确定是这样，因为我认为……我认为这……
into our understanding of culture war and unless it's going to become something so kind of broad reaching that it just becomes nebulous and pointless is the idea of progress it's the idea of whether you're on the side of progress or not so it it requires people who feel them that they're progressive and people who feel that that progress is actually a form of loss so a kind of conservatism there are of course you know there are people who define themselves absolutely as conservatives in in in in rome but yeah cato would be a great example but see but caesar is not um he he's upholding a kind of style it's a it's kind of flash it's a kind of um an appeal to the tastes of the people but it's not going against the very idea of Rome it's not
将其融入我们对文化战争的理解中，除非它变得如此宽泛，以至于变得模糊且毫无意义，否则核心就是“进步”的理念。这是关于你是否站在进步一边的问题。所以它需要那些认为自己是进步派的人，以及那些认为进步实际上是一种损失的人——也就是某种保守主义。当然，在罗马也有人绝对将自己定义为保守派，加图就是一个很好的例子。但凯撒不是，他维护的是一种风格，一种浮华，一种对大众品味的迎合，但这并没有违背罗马的本质理念，它不是……
kind of formulating the idea that there are customs and practices that are superseded that should be jettisoned I think if you want so if you want, the closest approximation to a culture war and i think that the christians who are opposing certain aspects of roman culture are doing it in a way that we could perhaps define as progressive they're kind of saying okay things can be improved things can be better and um the the traditions that you are are upholding are antiquated and should be jettisoned so so i wanted to ask you about that when christianity comes in because there surely you have you must have a sense i mean it's very hard to get hold of that now because our sources are so limited but you must have a sense of people in there in rome in the days of
在制定一种观念，即有些习俗和做法已经过时，应该被抛弃。我认为，如果你愿意的话，最接近文化战争的例子是那些反对罗马文化某些方面的基督徒，他们以一种我们或许可以定义为“进步”的方式行事。他们是在说：“好吧，事情可以改进，可以变得更好，你们所维护的传统已经过时，应该被抛弃。”所以我很想问你关于这一点，当基督教进入时，因为在那里你肯定有一种感觉——虽然现在很难把握，因为我们的资料非常有限——但你一定能感觉到在君士坦丁大帝及其继任者——好吧，我想更多是他的继任者——时期的罗马，人们在说：“我从小就被教导要相信X、Y、Z。现在我所相信的一切都被颠覆了。这些尖叫、刺耳的人（在这种情况下是基督徒）正在从我们手中夺走我们的国家——他们不会说‘国家’，而是‘世界’——并把一切都颠倒过来，这难道不可怕吗？我只是相信20年前人们所相信的东西，突然有人告诉我那全错了。”
constantine the great and his successors well i suppose more his successors who are saying you know i was always brought up to believe x y Y, and Z. And now everything that I believe has been turned on its head. And isn't it awful that these shrieking, strident people, in this case the Christians, are taking our country from us. I mean, they wouldn't have said our country, but our world from us. And turning everything on its head. I just believe what people believed 20 years ago. And suddenly I'm told that's all wrong.
（接上文）我甚至不知道正确的词汇是什么。我们知道那些行话。所以他们难道不是在说完全一样的事情吗？那么基督徒带入这场博弈的，首先是存在一种超越地方的普遍身份认同的观念。因此，相对于基督徒带来的“福音”，罗马传统并不那么重要，因为福音是真正普遍的。另一个观念是，罗马文化的某些方面不仅是不相关的，而且简直是恶魔般的，因此必须以某种我们或许可以称之为“进步”的名义被废除，因为基督徒会认为消除恶魔是在改善社会及其中每个人的生活。所以这包括像角斗士比赛、奴隶制……
I don't even know what the right words are. We know the lingo. So aren't they saying exactly that then so what christians are bringing in to the to the party is first of all the idea that there is a kind of universal identity that transcends the local so rome roman traditions are not that important relative to the good news that Christians bring, which are properly universal. And also the other idea is that certain aspects of Roman culture are not just kind of irrelevant, but literally demonic and therefore have to be abolished in the name of something that perhaps rather anachronistically we could call progress because christians would see the removal of the demonic as improving life for um society and everybody within it so is that things like gladiatorial yeah gladiatorial games slavery
有一个特别的事件非常出名，发生在四世纪末。参议院里有一个祭坛，叫“胜利祭坛”，它是罗马人过去荣耀的象征。那里有一尊胜利女神尼刻的雕像，可以追溯到与皮洛士的战争，甚至在汉尼拔之前。祭坛本身是奥古斯都为了庆祝他战胜安东尼和克利奥帕特拉而放置的。所以它绝对是……你知道，它就像纳尔逊纪念柱，它是罗马人视为体现其尚武荣耀的一切。丘吉尔的雕像。是的，绝对是。而基督徒讨厌它，因为它要求人们献祭，焚香，向那些基督徒视为恶魔的神灵献祭。所以他们不断煽动将其移除。357年，君士坦提乌斯二世确实将其移除了。后来尤利安继位，他被基督徒称为“叛教者”，因为他想重新引入异教。所以他又把它放了回来。然后在382年它又被移除了。执行此举的皇帝格拉提安随后在政变中丧生。他的同父异母兄弟瓦伦提尼安二世随后被请愿……
there's one there's one particular kind of incident which is which is famous which takes place in the late fourth century there is an altar in the senate house um called the altar of victory which serves as a symbol for the romans of their the glories of their past so there's a statue of victory nike which dates back to the wars with pyrrhus um so before the time of Hannibal even um and the altar itself is has been put there by Augustus to celebrate his victories over over Antony and Cleopatra so it's absolutely you know it's it's Nelson's column it's it's everything that the Romans kind of see as embodying their martial glory. Statue of Churchill. Yes, absolutely. And the Christians hate it because it requires people to offer,
把它带回来。这件事之所以有据可查，是因为我们有双方的记录。我们有一个叫西马库斯的参议员，一个异教徒参议员，他写信给皇帝说：“看，你们知道，‘己所不欲，勿施于人’，基督徒可以有他们的教堂，为什么我们不能有我们的祭坛？”这当然没问题。然后我们得到了米兰主教圣安布罗斯的回应，他说：“我们不能就此进行谈判，因为这是恶魔般的。它必须被清除。我们绝不妥协。”我认为在那里，你确实看到了我们社会中文化战争轮廓的一个原型例子。那种感觉是，对于那些认同我们可能称之为“进步事业”的人来说，某些事情是不可谈判的，过去留下的残渣不能仅仅被容忍，必须被清除。所以我认为，汤姆，你已经出色地反驳了你在节目开始时的论点，因为你刚才……对我来说，这非常有说服力。我的意思是，这听起来完全可以识别：安布罗斯是“觉醒派”（woke），而另一个人是“非觉醒派”，两者之间绝无妥协。所以我愿意承认，在基督教与既有社会的关系中，确实存在文化战争的因素。例如，基督教哲学家和神学家在对待异教文学时的焦虑中也存在这种因素。所以，在10世纪……
to burn incense, to offer sacrifice to these gods who Christians see as demonic. So they're constantly agitating to have it removed. And 357 Constantius II does remove it. Then he's succeeded by Julian, who is notoriously known by the Christians as the apostate because he wants to reintroduce paganism. So he brings it back in. Then it gets removed again in 382. And the emperor who does that, a guy called Gratian, then dies in a coup. And his half-brother um valentinian the second is then petitioned to
克吕尼的一位修道院长做了一个梦，他看到一个花瓶，里面装满了盘绕的蛇，三条盘绕的蛇。他醒来后，一位天使出现说：“这些蛇是维吉尔、贺拉斯和奥维德。所以你必须除掉它们。”与此同时，在拉文纳，有人说实际上我们应该研究维吉尔而不是福音书，因为它们更好。所以我猜这是一种……你知道，那里有一些我们所熟悉的趋势的预兆。但我认为，基本上在那里发生的是一个根本上的基督教社会与一个不认同自己是基督教的社会之间的紧张关系。我认为……基督徒会“取消”东西吗？例如，他们想取消文学吗？
bring it back and the reason that this is um is is very well documented is that we have both sides so we have a guy called simicus who is a senator pagan senator who's writing to the emperor and saying look you know live and let live um christians can have their churches why can't we have our altar sure that's fine and then we have have the response from St. Ambrose, who's the Bishop of Milan, saying we cannot negotiate with this because this is demonic. It has to be got rid of. We have no compromise at all. And I think there you do see a kind of a proto example of the contours that the culture wars in our society will take on. The sense that certain things for those who are identifying themselves with what we might call the progressive cause is non-negotiable that and and that the the detritus
并不是真的。有些人会，但这是一种少数派，但周围总有一种轻微的矛盾心理。我认为……我的意思是，我会争论说，比如在21世纪的美国大学里，人们在学习奥维德之前给出“触发警告”，这与基督徒在古代晚期对奥维德或维吉尔所感受到的矛盾心理有一种回响。我认为本质上，在这两种情况下，它都源于对“普遍性”和“进步”的深刻基督教假设。我认为这些是关键。汤姆，在这个时期，也就是古代晚期到中世纪早期，你还会看到大量关于图像的喧嚣。
of the past cannot just be tolerated it has to be removed so i think that tom i think you've you've brilliantly disproved your argument at the beginning of the program because i because you've just i mean that to me is utterly compelling i mean that sounds completely recognizable ambrose as well is woke and the other fellow is unwoke and never the compromise between so what i would what i would grant is that there is a there are certainly cultural war elements within christian Christianity's relationship to the pre-existing society and it's there for instance also in the anxieties that Christian philosophers and theologians feel in their attitude towards pagan literature so um so in the in in the 10th century
有一件事确实让我觉得是一种连续性，那就是目前显然有大量关于雕像、关于纪念人物的牌匾，以及你崇拜谁的“雕刻偶像”的争论。这在拜占庭就有，关于破坏偶像运动的争论，然后再次，我认为你难道没看到同样的事情吗？人们说：“好吧，我从小就被教导要相信X、Y、Z，我一直认为这些图像是我们文化中重要的一部分，它们是我们想象力和宗教、精神世界的核心，现在这些混蛋来了，粉饰它们，把它们除掉。”就像他们后来在宗教改革中所做的那样。这在我看来是一个贯穿过去2000年的迷人冲动：关于图像、关于你竖立谁、以及竖立图像是否正确，不断的战斗。但我当时在想这个问题，知道我们要谈论这个，我只是觉得那是不一样的，因为那是基督徒在用基督教术语争论应该做什么。所以关于拜占庭的圣像和16世纪图像的争论，双方都承认自己是基督徒，所以这是关于神学的争论……
there's an abbot of Cluny who has a dream in which he sees a vase and it's full of coiling snakes three coiling snakes and he wakes and an angel appears and says, these snakes are Virgil and Horace and Ovid. So you must get rid of them. Meanwhile, simultaneously in Ravenna, you have people who are saying that actually we should be studying Virgil rather than the Gospels because they're much better. So that I guess is a kind of, you know, there are kind of prefigurings there of trends that we recognise. But I think that basically what is happening there is that it's the tension between a fundamentally Christian society and a society that is not identifying itself as Christian. And I think that... Do the Christians cancel stuff? Do they want to cancel literature, for example?
双方都承认他们是在争论神学。但我认为他们并不认为对方是好基督徒，对吧？不，他们确实不认为对方是好基督徒。但我认为文化战争的定义是双方本质上都在辩论神学条款，但只有一方不承认这一点。好吧，向我解释一下。你认为一方是多元主义者，另一方不是。所以关于雕像问题……
Not really. Some do, but it's a kind of minority but there's always a slight ambivalence around it and i think that you know there are kind of i mean i would argue that the say you know people giving giving um warnings before trigger warnings before studying ovid or something in in a 21st century american university that there is a kind of echo there of the ambivalences that Christians felt, say, towards Ovid or Virgil in late antiquity. And I think that essentially, but in both cases, it's bred of deeply Christian assumptions about both the universal and the progressive. And I think that those are the keys. What you also get in this period, Tom, well, sort of late antiquity, early medieval, is a huge amount of hullabaloo about images.
当然，基督教文化绝对引入了对雕像的巨大矛盾心理。竖立雕像来纪念伟大人物的想法是非常具有文化特异性的，这是希腊人有，特别是罗马人有的。所以罗马人总是竖立他们伟大将军和伟人的雕像。本质上，现代欧洲这样做的趋势反映了对什么是公共空间中可接受事物的基督教理解的某种松动。所以，直到17世纪，然后进入18世纪，你才开始听到人们说……
And one thing that does strike me as a kind of continuity is that obviously there is a torrent of stuff at the moment about statues and about plaques to people and, you know, who you celebrate in the graven image. And that's there in, you know, that's in their byzantium and the arguments about iconoclasm and then there again i think don't you see the same kind of thing people who say well i've been brought up to believe x y and z i've always believed that these images were an important part of that they're central to our our culture and our
“我们也有伟人。”你知道，这与罗马的日益认同。所以18世纪被称为“奥古斯都时代”。正是在18世纪，你开始看到人们竖立伟人、将军和国王的雕像，还有慈善家、基督教慈善家。是的，所以它们竖起来了。这就是为什么我们公共空间中的大多数雕像都代表着18、19和20世纪初的人物，因为这是一个古典主义时代，这是一个回顾罗马时代的时代。现在，我认为今天围绕雕像的焦虑源于某种深刻的基督教思想，只是那些反对它的人不会承认那是基督教的。但本质上，那种“我们不能竖立雕像，因为它纪念的是堕落和邪恶”的感觉。所以如果它是一个奴隶贩子、帝国主义者或任何其他什么人，你知道，这非常……这是在利用一种假设，即从奴隶身上获利，或者在征服大片领土并在此过程中杀人，是不值得赞扬的。这些假设源于基督教历史的伟大遗产。但它们已经脱离了特定基督教教义的束缚，现在只是在空气中渗透，人们只是呼吸着它们……
imaginative and religious a spiritual world and now these bastards are coming along and whitewashing them and getting rid of them just as they obviously later do in the reformation and that seems to me to be that's a fascinating impulse running through the last 2000 years constant battles about images and who you put up and whether it's right to put up an image at all but i was i was kind of thinking about this knowing that we were going to be talking about this and i just kind of have this i feel that that's different because those are christians arguing in christian terms about what should be done so the arguments about about icons in byzantium and about images in the 16th century are people who who both accept that they're christians on both sides so it's it's arguments
并认为这是理所当然的。但我认为，对我来说，这就是我所看到的文化战争：它是那些不承认自己是神学争论的神学争论。那么，让我们回到宗教改革……因为我以为我们会花很多时间谈论宗教改革。因为当乔治·弗洛伊德被杀、“黑人的命也是命”运动开始时，当时我们显然处于封锁状态，那是去年，2020年中期。所以它垄断了……基本上它是除了新冠病毒之外的唯一新闻。就在那一刻，我正在写我的儿童书，关于亨利八世和他的六个妻子，这是一个很好的植入广告……
about theology where both are recognizing that they're christians on both sides so it's it's arguments about theology where both are recognizing that they're arguing about theology i think they don't think the other people are good christians though do they no they don't they really don't think the other people are good christians but i think i think the definition of a culture war is where both sides are essentially debating theological terms but only one side one side doesn't recognise it. Okay, so explain that to me. You think one side pluralist and the other not pluralist. So on the statues issue,
实际上，我正在写我的儿童书，关于亨利八世和他的六个妻子，所以我正在读关于宗教改革的书，比如彼得·马歇尔那本伟大的书《异端与改革者》，关于英国宗教改革的，我认为这是我读过的最好的历史书之一。我心想，这太不可思议地相似了。你知道，这些由好天主教徒写的记录，讲述了当新教徒带着外来思想出现时，他们的震惊和恐惧……
there is absolutely, of course, Christian culture introduces a huge ambivalence about statues. And the idea of putting up statues to memorialize great figures is is a very culturally specific one it's it's one that the greeks have and particularly the romans have so the romans the romans are always shoving up statues of their great generals and their great men and essentially the the the trend in modern Europe to do that reflects a kind of loosening of specifically Christian understandings about what is acceptable in the public space. So it's in the 17th century, really, and then through into the 18th century, that you start getting people saying,
你知道，聪明、人脉广、富有的商人之类的，带着沿着贸易路线传播的欧洲思想。你知道，这些文盲（指被指责的人）在说：“不，你所相信的一切都是错的。你应该教育自己。你应该净化你的教会。你应该做所有这些事。”我以为这里有如此多的连续性。你知道，很难分辨新闻在哪里结束，而这本历史书从哪里开始。我完全同意，你没看到……不，那里绝对有连续性，我完全同意。只是对我来说，“文化战争”这个词……它是在俾斯麦的德国被创造出来的，然后随着它在美国的使用而演变。我认为当然，所有这些趋势、所有这些战争、所有这些战斗都是从基督教范式中继承下来的。只是我认为我们所说的“文化战争”是指那些不承认自己是神学争论的神学争论，而在宗教改革中，他们承认。所以我完全同意，阅读那些正在变成新教的城镇中关于破坏偶像运动的记录，人们走进大教堂，砸碎十字架，嘲笑圣母雕像，把圣徒雕像扔进河里。我的意思是，这确实令人震惊，但它是以公开的神学术语完成的。
you know, we too have great men. know this is this this increasing identification with with particularly rome so so you know the 18th century is known as the augustan age so it's in the 18th century that you start getting people putting up statues of of great men of generals and kings but also benefactors christian benefactors um yeah so so up they go and that's why most of the statues in our public spaces are represent figures from the from the um the 18th and the 19th and the early 20th centuries because this is a this is a classicizing age this is an age that is looking back to the roman age now i think that the the anxieties around statues today are bred of kind of deeply christian ideas it's just that the people who are campaigning
对它们的辩护是根据圣经和神学给出的。现在的情况并非如此。所以当人们争论跨性别权利、雕像、堕胎或任何其他问题时，争论往往被框定为……我的意思是，通常是基督徒对抗进步派。所以现在是基督徒成了保守派，而进步派则背弃了这一点，将其视为愚昧的迷信。但我认为，进步派从基督教历史和神学的遗产中汲取的，与那些自称是基督徒的人一样多，只是他们没有意识到这一点。所以这就是我认为文化战争……
against it, they wouldn't recognize that as being Christian. But essentially, the sense that we can't have a statue up because it commemorates depravity and evil. So if it's a slave trader or an imperialist or whatever, you know, this is very, this is drawing on the assumption that to make a profit from slaves or to conquer vast reaches of territory and kill people while doing so is not something that is deserving of praise. And these are assumptions that are bred of the great heritage of Christian history. But they've escaped the moorings of specific christian doctrine and they now just kind of percolate in the air and people just kind of breathe them in
不赞同你的论点，汤姆。是的，所以爱丽丝·罗伯茨绝对是一个在任何其他背景下都不可想象的人物，除了某种新教基督教背景。但她不接受这一点。这就是让她成为文化斗士，而不是基督教内部战争中的基督教参赛者的原因。而且是一个如此有趣的喜剧人物。但无论如何……
and and and take them for granted but that i think is for me that's what i would see the culture wars as being is that it's it's it's arguments about theology that do not recognize themselves as being arguments about theology so then when you go back to so let's go back to the the reformation um because i thought we'd spend a lot of time talking about the reformation because when when the sort of the george floyd was killed black lives matter kicked off there was a you know ton of stuff we're obviously in lockdown at that point that was last year in the sort of middle of 2020 so it monopolized it was the one story that wasn't the coronavirus basically and at that very moment I was writing my children this is a good plug
所以这还有一个维度，我认为非常有趣，我想你可能会完全拒绝。那就是更公开的政治维度。所以，对我来说，我会争论——显然你会不同意——英国政治……
actually I was writing my children's book about Henry VIII and his six wives and so I was reading books about the reformation like Peter Marshall's great book heretics and reformers about a brilliant one of the best history books I think I've ever read, about the English Reformation. And I was thinking to myself how uncannily similar this is. You know, these accounts by sort of good Catholics of their shock and their horror as Protestants with imported ideas,
一直是一种文化战争。我的意思是，这就是罗伯特·汤姆斯在他的书《英国人及其历史》中所争论的。他认为英国政治一直是一种文化战争……我的意思是，这就是罗伯特·汤姆斯在他的书《英国人及其历史》中所争论的。他认为英国政治特别具有这种文化战争维度，它一直存在。一直存在宗教鸿沟，你知道，托利党和保守党在投票站是“英国国教派”，而那种自由派左翼倾向，特别是在中产阶级生活中，一直是由某种宗教非国教派……
you know, clever, well-connected, affluent merchants and stuff, with European ideas that have travelled along the trade routes. You know, these illiterate people who are saying, no, everything you believed was wrong. You know, you should educate yourself. You should purge your church. You should do all this. And I thought there was such continuity here. You know, it's hard to tell where the news ends and this history book begins i completely agree you don't see no there is
以及异议传统所驱动的。实际上，当我回顾政治诞生的时期，也就是我们所认为的政治，所以你在谈论17世纪末、18世纪初，我的意思是，它充满了关于文化战争类问题的争论。我的意思是，我知道你读过我几周前为《UnHerd》写的关于萨切弗雷尔案的文章。在那里，你有一个传教士……
absolutely there is continuity there i completely agree it's just that for me the word culture war is it kind of you know it it's it it's coined um in um bismarck's germany and then as it as it evolves with its use in amer I think that of course all these all these trends all these wars all these battles are inherited from Christian paradigms it's just that I think that what we mean by culture wars it refers to arguments about theology that do not recognize themselves as being about theology whereas whereas in the Reformation they do. So I completely agree that reading the accounts of the iconoclasm in towns and cities that are becoming Protestant, where people are going into cathedrals and smashing crucifixes and kind of mocking statues of the Virgin and chucking statues of saints into the river. I mean, it is kind of shocking, but it's done in overtly theological terms.
你知道，那是1710年大选中最大的单一议题。这是一个谴责辉格党和异议人士的传教士，托利党人抓住了这一点，他们利用它，并将其放大为一个重大的国家政治议题，以至于现在人们会说：“哦，典型的托利党人，人为制造文化战争”之类的。我的意思是，人们在17、18世纪就在做这件事了。所以对我来说，文化战争和党派议会政治在某种程度上一直齐头并进。我并不不同意，我读过你的文章，觉得非常棒。而且人们……
The justifications for them are given in terms of scripture and theology. That's not what happens now. So when people argue about trans rights or about statues or abortion or whatever the arguments are framed often i mean often so abortion or gay rights or something like that it's it's often cast as you know it's christians against progressives so it's the christians who are the conservatives now and it's the progressives who are turning their back on that as kind of benighted superstition but what i think is that the progressives are drawing just as much on that inheritance of christian history and theology as the the self-confessing christians it's just that they don't recognize it so that that's that's what i think a culture will not
还没读过它，它几周前在《UnHerd》上，不是吗？我的意思是，我觉得它非常棒，它真的让我思考这个问题。关于这一点，我的想法是，我会说……比如，在内战后的护国公时期，当你有所有这些相互竞争的宗教教派在互相辩论时，我不会认为那是文化战争，因为我认为那仍然是在公开的基督教术语中进行的。但像“辉格党主义”那样可能演变成“进步”的东西——所以辉格党主义是一种世俗的进步观念，它绝对与托利党关于英国国教的观念相冲突，即它应该是……这是被诅咒的。所以我完全同意，我认为那是……
approve of your argument there tom yes so Yes, so Alice Roberts is absolutely a figure who would be unthinkable in any other context except a kind of Protestant Christian one. But she doesn't accept that. And that's what makes her a culture warrior rather than a Christian contestant in an intra-Christian war. And such an entertaining comic figure. But anyway,
你知道，那是现代文化战争的前身。因为有了辉格党主义，你得到了……你知道，这显然是一个巨大的神学概念，它只能出现于——而且它显然确实出现于——17世纪国教与异议人士之间的争论。但它失去了……你知道，它摆脱了那种束缚。所以我认为那种18世纪的争论，我完全接受其有效性。你认为这些事情背后是否有一种气质上的冲动？我们都是……你知道，吉尔伯特和萨利文有这种“自由派”或“小保守派”，我们生来就是小自由派或小保守派。我的意思是，我们生来就是……
so there's one other dimension to this which I think is really interesting that you, I imagine, will completely reject. And that is the sort of more overtly political dimension. So, to me, I would argue, and you clearly would disagree, that British politics
文化斗士。你不认为在某种程度上，我们都有本能吗？即使你没有思考过这些问题，或者你没有沉浸在历史或神学中，人们对这些事情也有非常本能、直觉的反应。他们是重视传统和保守主义、重视事情一贯做法的人吗？还是他们想看到自己站在进步的一边？他们是否对站在历史错误的一边感到恐惧？我的意思是，这些事情是相当天生的，不是吗？你不觉得吗？是的，但我认为……我……
has always been a kind of culture war. I mean, this is what, for example, Robert Toombs argues in his book The English and Their History. He argues that British politics has always been a kind of culture war that the I mean this is what for example Robert Toombs argues in his book the English and their history he argues the English politics specifically has always had this culture war dimension that it's always been there's always been a religious gap you know the the Tories and the Conservatives are the kind of Church of England at the voting booth and that the sort of liberal left-wing tendency, particularly in middle-class life, has always been driven by kind of religious non-conformity
听到我这么说你不会感到惊讶，我确实认为基督教从根本上改变了辩论的条款。因为在古代，基本上每个人都是保守派。所以即使他们想改变事情，而且他们经常这样做——我的意思是，这是一个持续的变革过程——但他们总是会通过说他们正在回到事情一贯的做法来证明这一点。所以当雅典民主建立时，这个极其激进的实验，他们说：“好吧，我们只是回到忒修斯建立的东西。”当奥古斯都……你知道，他在共和国的废墟上建立他的独裁统治时，他说：“好吧，我正在……回归基础，我正在恢复共和国，我正在恢复事情一贯的样子。”我认为基督教改变了什么，以及……
and by the tradition of dissent. And actually, you know, when I look back at the period that politics was born, that what we would recognise as politics, so you're talking about late 17th, early 18th century, I mean, it's shot through with arguments about sort of culture war kind of issues i mean the example i know you've read this piece that i wrote a few weeks ago for unheard about the sucheverall case so there you've got a preacher
在我们的社会中真正显现的是这样一种观念：实际上，为了改变而改变本身就成了一种好事，存在着一种“进步的弧线”，你要么站在那条进步的弧线上，要么就不站在。所以我同意有一种……你知道，你要么有一种……你享受变革，你享受它所代表的兴奋，要么你有一种本能的退缩，你只是希望事情能保持原样。我同意那是一种气质上的东西。但我认为基督教改变的是，那随后变成了一种更具意识形态的分歧。我认为我们现在生活在那之后的余波中。我也认为我们可能已经谈论得够久了，我们需要休息一下。你觉得呢？
you know that that's the the single biggest issue in the general election of 1710 um and it's a preacher who has condemned the wigs and condemned dissenters and the tories pick it up and they run with it and they amplify it into a sort of major national political issue in a way that people now would say oh typical tour is confecting a culture war all this sort of stuff i mean that people are doing it right back then in the 17th sort of 18th centuries so to me culture wars and sort of you know partisan parliamentary politics have always gone hand in hand to some extent i i don't disagree and i i've read you know you know i read your essay and thought it was fantastic um and and people
我刚才就在想。我正在想我该如何带我们进入休息时间。汤姆，我想你需要武装起来，磨快你的武器，战斗将在休息之后恢复，在听完赞助商的话之后。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余温》。
haven't read it it was it was in unheard a couple of weeks ago wasn't it i mean i thought and i thought it was fantastic and it kind of really made me think about this so and what i think about that is that i would say that um say that the the disagreements the conflicts the tensions the cultural arguments say in the period of the protectorate after the civil war where you have all these kind of rival religious denominations all debating with each other i would not see that as being a cultural because i think that's still being conducted in in in overtly christian terms but something like wiggery that that might evolve is progress so wiggery it's a kind of secular idea of progress and that is absolutely coming up against the kind of tory idea of the church of england that it should be you know that this this is anathema so I I do completely agree that I think that that is kind of
这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余温》，欢迎回到《文化战争》，汤姆·霍兰和我现在正身处其中。汤姆，美国。美国，我们已经做过一整期关于“美国化”的播客了，
um you know that's the precursor to the modern culture war because with Whiggery you're getting the idea of of you know it's clearly a massively theological concept that could only have emerged and it clearly does emerge from from the uh the the argument between um established church and and dissenters in the 17th century but it it looses it you know it slips that that mooring so i think that that kind of 18th century argument is i i completely accept the validity of that um and what what do you think about whether there's a sort of temperamental as it were um impulse behind these things that we are we are all little you know gilbert and sullivan had this liberals or little we're all born little liberals or little conservatives i mean we're all born
所以我们不需要再做一次。但美国显然在文化战争中扮演了重要角色。现在，我告诉你我的论点，然后你可以反驳它。我的意思是，我认为基本上，当定居者和清教徒之类的人去美国时，他们带走了文化战争，而你在美国看到的所有争论都源于17、18世纪英国、英格兰和苏格兰的争论。发生的事情是，美国现在已经把这些争论重新出口回给我们了。所以我们认为它们是美国的，但实际上它们最终是……
culture warriors do you not think to an extent we all have an instinctive even if you haven't thought about the issues or you're not steeped in the history or the theology or whatever, people have a very instinctive, visceral reaction to these things. Are they somebody who values tradition and conservatism and how things have always been done? Or do they want to see themselves on the side of progress? And are they horrified at the thought of being on the wrong side of history and all that stuff? I mean, those things are quite innate,'re quite innate aren't they don't you think yes but i think that um i it
某种辉格党、托利党、老派事业、内战时代的争论。它们在美国以一种如此强烈的形式幸存下来，因为美国比英国宗教色彩浓厚得多。所以，在我看来，他们文化战争的强度是一种非常受宗教启发的东西。
won't surprise you to hear me say this i i do think that christianity radically alters the terms of the debate because um back in ancient times basically everyone was a conservative so even if they wanted to change things, and often, of course, they did. I mean, there's a constant process of change. But they would always justify it by saying that they were going back to the way that things were always done. So when the Athenian democracy gets set up, this incredibly radical experiment, they say, well, we're just going back to do what what theseus set up and and and augustus when he and you know he he plants his autocracy on the rubble of the republic he says well i'm you know back to basics i'm restoring the republic i'm restoring the way that things always were and i think that um that what changes with christianity and what and what
你相信吗？完全相信。是的，我知道你会……我当然相信，非常好。我认为……我们在“美国化”播客中谈到过，这就是为什么当美国文化斗士打喷嚏时，我们如此容易感冒的原因之一，因为基本上我们对它没有天然免疫力，因为它源于我们。所以我认为……但我再次认为，使美国的文化战争特别激烈的原因，正如你所说，是因为它是一个比英国长期以来更坚定的基督教社会。我认为在60年代和70年代发生的事情是……
is really manifest in our society now is the idea that actually change for its own sake becomes a good, that there is such a thing as an arc of progress and that you're either with that arc of progress or you're not. So I agree that there is a kind of, you know, you either have a kind of, you know, you relish change and you enjoy the excitement that it represents, or you have a kind of instinctive shrinking from it and you just wish that things could stay as they were. And I agree that's a temperamental thing. But I think that what changes with Christianity is that that then becomes much more kind of ideological divide. And I think that we live in the kind of aftermath of that now. I also think that we've possibly talked about this long enough and that we need a break. What do you think?
那种宗教文化以一种非常、非常深刻的方式发生了突变，其规模类似于1520年代，即宗教改革的开端。因为你在50年代和60年代得到的是民权运动，这是一个非常、非常深刻的基督教运动。马丁·路德·金牧师。马丁·路德·金牧师，是的。他的语言完全沉浸在圣经叙事中。所以出埃及记的语言，上帝引导奴隶走出埃及的观念，他站在被压迫者一边，而不是站在法老一边。
I was just thinking that. I was thinking about how I was going to get us into the break. Tom, I think you need to tool up, sharpen your weapons, and the battle will resume after this, after a word from our sponsors. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
我刚才也在想这个问题。我在想该怎么带大家进入中场休息。汤姆，我想你需要武装起来，磨快你的武器，战斗将在稍后继续，在听完赞助商的消息之后。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History and welcome back to The Culture Wars, which Tom Holland and I are engaged in right now. Tom, America. America, we've had a whole podcast about Americanisation,
这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的来源，在问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。再说一遍，therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余谈》，欢迎回到《文化战争》，汤姆·霍兰德和我现在正深陷其中。汤姆，美国。美国，我们已经做过一整期关于美国化的播客了，
so we don't need to do that again. But America clearly plays a huge part in The Culture Wars. Now now i'll tell you my thesis and then then you can reject it um i mean i think basically the when the settlers and the the sort of puritans and stuff went to america they took the culture wars with them and that the arguments all the arguments you see in America are descended from 17th, 18th century British, sort of English and Scottish arguments, and that what's happened is that America has now re-exported those arguments back to us. So we see them as American, but actually they are ultimately
所以我们不需要再重复了。但美国显然在文化战争中扮演了重要角色。现在，让我说说我的论点，然后你可以反驳它。我的意思是，我认为基本上当定居者和那些清教徒之类的人去到美国时，他们把文化战争也带了过去，你在美国看到的所有争论，其实都是源自17、18世纪英国，也就是英格兰和苏格兰的争论，而现在发生的事情是，美国已经把这些争论重新出口回了我们这里。所以我们把它们看作是美国的，但实际上它们最终是
kind of Whig, Tory, good old cause, Civil War era kinds of arguments. And they've survived in America in such a sort of intense form because America is much more religious than the UK is. So the intensity of their culture wars, it seems to me, is a very religiously inspired thing.
某种辉格党、托利党、老派事业、内战时期的争论。它们在美国以一种非常强烈的形式存活了下来，因为美国比英国宗教氛围浓厚得多。所以，在我看来，他们文化战争的激烈程度，很大程度上是受宗教启发的。
Do you buy that? Completely. Yes, I knew you i do i could of course very good and i think that you know we talked about that in the americanization podcast that's one of the reasons why we're so susceptible to catching colds when american cultural warriors sneeze is that basically we we have no natural immunity to it because because it came from us um so i i think but again i i think that that what has made culture wars in america particularly virulent is as you say that it they are it is a much more committedly christian society than than britain's been for a fair while. And I think that what happens in the 60s and 70s
你认同吗？完全认同。是的，我知道你会认同，非常好。我认为，正如我们在美国化那期播客中讨论的那样，这就是为什么当美国文化斗士打喷嚏时，我们如此容易感冒的原因之一，因为基本上我们对它没有天然免疫力，因为它本来就源自我们。所以我认为，再次强调，我认为让美国文化战争变得如此恶毒的原因，正如你所说，是因为它是一个比英国长期以来更虔诚的基督教社会。我认为在60年代和70年代发生的事情是
is that that religious culture mutates in a very, very profound way, in a way that is kind of analogous to the 1520s, really. I mean, it's a change in the fabric of Christian thought on that scale, beginnings of the Reformation. Because what you get in the 50s and 60s is the civil rights movement, which is a deeply, deeply Christian movement. The Reverend Martin Luther King. The Reverend Martin Luther King, yeah. And his language is absolutely steeped in biblical narratives. So the language of Exodus, the idea that God leads slaves out of Egypt, that he's on the side of those who are oppressed rather than on the side of Pharaoh.
那种宗教文化以一种非常、非常深刻的方式发生了变异，其程度真的类似于1520年代。我的意思是，那是基督教思想结构上的一次大规模变革，也就是宗教改革的开端。因为你在50年代和60年代看到的是民权运动，那是一场极其深刻的基督教运动。马丁·路德·金牧师。是的，马丁·路德·金牧师。他的语言完全沉浸在圣经叙事中。比如出埃及记的语言，上帝带领奴隶走出埃及，他站在被压迫者一边，而不是站在法老一边。
And of course, he's invoking Christ, the guy who dies the death of a slave all the time. And essentially, that's what gives the civil rights movement its traction, is that he is able to remind white American american christians that if there is no dual greek then there is no black or white in christ and and white christians accept essentially you know within limits accept the justice of that argument and and that establishes a template for other people who come from um sidelined communities, people who feel that they've been suffering oppression from majority rule to do the same. So gay rights would be an example of that.
当然，他援引了基督，那个一直承受着奴隶之死的人。从本质上讲，这正是民权运动获得推动力的原因，因为他能够提醒美国白人基督徒，如果不再有希腊人与犹太人之分，那么在基督里也就没有黑人或白人之分。白人基督徒在一定程度上接受了这一论点的正义性，这为其他来自边缘化社区的人们，那些感到自己受到多数统治压迫的人们，建立了一个可以效仿的模板。所以，同性恋权利就是一个例子。
I guess even feminism would be an example of that, both of which gain enormous kind of sustenance from the example of the civil rights movement and the campaign for racial justice. But the problem, I guess, for practicing Christians with feminism and even more with gay rights is that the arguments and certainly the rhetoric rub up against a traditional Christian understanding and kind of scriptural dictates in a way that the campaign for racial justice hadn't. And so what you get over the course of the 70s is that, you know, in culture
我想甚至女权主义也是一个例子，这两者都从民权运动和种族正义运动的榜样中获得了巨大的支持。但对于虔诚的基督徒来说，女权主义，尤其是同性恋权利的问题在于，它们的论点，当然还有它们的修辞，与传统的基督教理解和某种圣经教条发生了冲突，而种族正义运动则没有这种情况。所以，在70年代的过程中，你所看到的是，你知道，在文化
wars, it forces people to take sides. And so people who are practicing Christians increasingly come to identify as conservatives, people who are under attack from people who are not Christian. And progressives, likewise, increasingly come to identify Christianity as being something repressive, negative, something that has to be conservative, fossilized, something that has to be oppressive, something that has to be jettisoned. And so essentially, those are the kind of the battle lines that the trenches still run across America to to this day where you have people who say i'm christian i hate progressives you have progressives who say i'm a progressive i hate christians but basically both sides are articulating arguments drawn from the same kind of great seedbed of christian thought so i think you know it's it's
战争中，它迫使人们选边站。因此，虔诚的基督徒越来越倾向于认同保守派，认为自己受到了非基督徒的攻击。同样，进步派也越来越倾向于将基督教视为一种压制性的、消极的东西，一种必须是保守的、僵化的、必须是压迫性的、必须被抛弃的东西。所以从本质上讲，这就是那些战壕线，至今仍横跨美国，在那里你会有说“我是基督徒，我讨厌进步派”的人，也会有说“我是进步派，我讨厌基督徒”的进步派，但基本上双方都在阐述源自同一种伟大的基督教思想温床的论点，所以我认为，你知道，这
not a christian against progressive war it's it's it's's a Christian civil war but what makes it a culture war in my light is that only one side recognises that Have you read this book by James Davison Hunter so this is the book that enshrines the term culture wars published in 1991 American sociologist now what he basically says is it's the clash between the orthodox and the progressive
不是一场基督徒对抗进步派的战争，这是一场基督教内战。但在我看来，之所以称其为文化战争，是因为只有一方意识到了这一点。你读过詹姆斯·戴维森·亨特的那本书吗？那本书确立了“文化战争”这个术语，由一位美国社会学家于1991年出版。他基本上说的是，这是正统派与进步派之间的冲突。
so he says you don't have to be a christian to be on the orthodox side you can you just believe in tradition you believe in the nuclear family you believe in you know your country in the military and all these kinds of things and then there's the progressives and he said that you know it's very hard to find that politics is increasingly being fought on out on those lines. And obviously now people talk a lot, so political scientists in Britain talk a lot about how the Conservatives, for example,
所以他说，你不必非得是基督徒才能站在正统派一边，你只需要相信传统，相信核心家庭，相信你的国家、军队以及所有这些东西。然后是进步派。他说，你知道，很难发现政治正越来越多地沿着这些路线进行斗争。显然，现在人们谈论很多，英国的政治学家谈论很多关于保守党，例如，
have moved from being sort of the Thatcherite party, the party of neoliberalism, as people call it, to being one that fights on more overtly cultural grounds, cultural conservative grounds. And people sometimes talk about that as though this is this tremendous new thing. But it seems to me that politics has always been fought out on that. There's always been the orthodox progressive, particularly in America, in American politics. I think that that tension has kind of always been there.
已经从所谓的撒切尔主义政党，即人们所说的新自由主义政党，转变为一个在更公开的文化基础上，即文化保守主义基础上进行斗争的政党。人们有时谈论这一点，好像这是一个了不起的新事物。但在我看来，政治一直都是在这些问题上进行斗争的。一直都有正统派与进步派之争，特别是在美国，在美国政治中。我认为这种紧张关系一直都存在。
It's only been there since the end of the Second World War. There's no doubt about that. Yeah. And I think escalating since the 60s. I think think so i think the 60s is a really crucial decade but i thought also what was brilliant in your essay which i also think is completely true is that um the culture war issues are a bit like personalities in politics that politicians are always saying people aren't really interested in this kind of nonsense people just want to talk about you know the inflation rate yeah nhs funding or something
它只是在二战结束后才存在。毫无疑问。是的。而且我认为自60年代以来一直在升级。我想是的，我认为60年代是一个非常关键的十年。但我还认为，你的文章中非常精彩且我认为完全正确的一点是，文化战争议题有点像政治中的个性问题，政客们总是说人们对这种废话不感兴趣，人们只想谈论通货膨胀率、NHS（国民医疗服务体系）资金或其他什么。
but it's it's it's evident that culture wars kind of blaze into fire because for lots of people they're enormous fun well you have i mean you know i have very strong views about this so i think strong views people people who are interested in politics i think i think one of the extraordinary things about people who are interested in politics is often they don't really understand they're very interested in politics but that makes them very bad judges of politics and how politics works because they're interested in it. So they because they're super interested in politics, they think that that that everybody else is interested in the same things that they are. It's rather like somebody who's incredibly interested in a particular sport and in the sort of statistics of it, understanding what other people see in it. Often they don't.
但显而易见，文化战争之所以燃起大火，是因为对很多人来说，它们非常有意思。我的意思是，你知道，我对这一点有非常强烈的看法，所以我认为强烈的观点……那些对政治感兴趣的人，我认为对政治感兴趣的人的一个非凡之处在于，他们往往并不真正理解，他们对政治非常感兴趣，但这使他们成为政治及其运作方式的糟糕评判者，因为他们太感兴趣了。所以，因为他们对政治超级感兴趣，他们认为其他人也对同样的事情感兴趣。这就像一个对某项运动及其统计数据非常感兴趣的人，试图理解其他人从中看到了什么。他们往往不理解。
And I think with politics, these arguments that sort of political obsessives and kind of guardian colonists think are contrived and confected about flags and statues, you will ordinary people, as it were, ordinary people, I know I sound like I'm getting into my column right in the vein, but sort of, as it were, ordinary people, people know I sound like I'm getting into my column writing vein, but sort of, as it were, ordinary people, people who are not very interested in politics, find those much more interesting subjects than exactly that, some arcane discussion about inflation or something.
我认为在政治上，那些政治狂热分子和《卫报》专栏作家认为是被捏造和拼凑出来的关于旗帜和雕像的争论，普通人——正如人们所说，普通人，我知道我听起来像是在写我的专栏——正如人们所说，普通人，那些对政治不太感兴趣的人，发现这些话题比关于通货膨胀或其他什么的深奥讨论要有趣得多。
They are very emotive, very powerful subjects, and always have been. And that's true the other way around, isn't it? That people on the left, likewise, are equally as obsessed by these topics as people on the right. Yes, I think that's probably true. They're more emotive to people on the left, aren't they? But that raises that left-right issue. It raises another interesting dimension, which I don't think quite fits with your theology theology thing which is a big element of the culture wars right now in britain are about britishness and about patriotism so orwell would have recognized all this because orwell in the 1940s he says you
它们是非常情绪化、非常有力量的主题，而且一直都是。反过来也是如此，不是吗？左派人士同样像右派人士一样沉迷于这些话题。是的，我想这可能是真的。它们对左派人士来说更具情绪化，不是吗？但这提出了那个左右翼的问题。它提出了另一个有趣的维度，我不认为它完全符合你的神学理论，即目前英国文化战争的一个重要因素是关于“英国性”和爱国主义。所以奥威尔会认出这一切，因为奥威尔在20世纪40年代说你
know he mocks orwell orwell is the great man of course he's every conservative columnist-to for kind of quotations because he's kind of on the left but he loves nothing better than basically mocking other lefties and he sort of says you know the british intelligentsia they get their cooking from paris and their opinions from moscow they would rather be seen stealing from a poor box than standing to sing god save the king and all this sort of thing and there's this interesting element of kind of national peculiarly national self-loathing you do get that a bit i think in america but you know the british i think lead the world i mean if we do leave the world on one thing it is self-flagellation about our sins and i wonder how that fits into york because i think that's there's a really interesting and strange thing at the heart of of Britishness that has always been there to some extent, which is a kind of we are uniquely sinful. The British project.
知道，他嘲笑奥威尔——奥威尔当然是伟人，他是每位保守派专栏作家的引用来源，因为他某种程度上属于左派，但他最喜欢做的事基本上就是嘲笑其他左派。他某种程度上说，你知道，英国知识分子从巴黎获取烹饪方式，从莫斯科获取观点，他们宁愿被看到从穷人的捐款箱里偷钱，也不愿站着唱《天佑国王》，诸如此类。有一种有趣的、某种特殊的民族自我厌恶的元素。我想在美国你也会有一点这种感觉，但你知道，英国人我认为领先世界——我的意思是，如果我们在一件事上领先世界，那就是对我们罪孽的自我鞭笞。我想知道这如何符合你的观点，因为我认为在英国性的核心有一种非常有趣且奇怪的东西，在某种程度上一直存在，那就是一种我们独特地有罪的感觉。英国计划。
So you go. I mean, you know, there's the word sinful immediately. But then but then you see if it's christian why don't other christian countries have it well because the french i don't think have it to the same extent you know the dutch are very proud of their empire um all those kinds of why don't other people have the same self-flagellating instinct that let's say the british intelligentsia have well i think i think Well, I think that, I mean, every country tends to be Christian in a different way. Okay. So there's a kind of different inheritance. broader world has been so formative both for the british themselves but also for um people who have
所以你看。我的意思是，你知道，立刻就出现了“有罪”这个词。但随后，你看，如果它是基督教的，为什么其他基督教国家没有这种感觉？嗯，因为我不认为法国人有同样程度的感觉，你知道，荷兰人对他们的帝国非常自豪，所有这些原因……为什么其他人没有像英国知识分子那样的自我鞭笞本能？嗯，我想，我想……嗯，我认为，我的意思是，每个国家往往以不同的方式成为基督教国家。好吧。所以有一种不同的传承。更广阔的世界对英国人本身以及对那些
had the british turn up and and be informative on them um the the kind of tension that exists within christianity the the suspicion of of the specifically national and the embrace of the universal manifests itself in a distinctive way so if you if you think if you you look back to the um the altar of victory essentially the argument is that um there is a universal christian identity that this is this is the answer and that um the the legacies of of kind of Roman militarism and imperialism are specific are not it's not just that they're specific to the Romans and therefore not of universal import but also that they're malign and malevolent and that's always been a a deep strain within within christianity i mean it's what catholic means universal um
曾被英国人接触并受到影响的人来说，都具有塑造性。基督教内部存在的这种紧张关系，即对特定民族性的怀疑和对普遍性的拥抱，以一种独特的方式表现出来。所以如果你回顾胜利祭坛，本质上的论点是，存在一种普遍的基督教身份，这就是答案，而且罗马军国主义和帝国主义的遗产是具体的，不仅仅是它们对罗马人来说是具体的，因此不具有普遍意义，而且它们是恶毒和邪恶的。这在基督教内部一直是一种深刻的倾向。我的意思是，这就是“天主教”意味着“普遍”的意思。
but obviously i i think that there is a kind of huge human impulse to identify with the local over the universal at the same time and i think a huge amount of the argument in in in britain therefore revolves around that issue should you emphasize the the universal over the local and it's the citizens of the world first sorry that the citizens of somewhere versus the citizens of nowhere isn't it i mean that's the from the theresa may speech yes i mean because that was an interesting one because now this is maybe the difference between us when i heard that speech i mean i'm the only person in the world who would admit to this. Certainly the only person who does a history podcast. I thought, yes, great.
但显然，我认为人类有一种巨大的冲动，即同时认同局部而非普遍。我认为英国的大量争论因此围绕着这个问题展开：你应该强调普遍性还是局部性？这就是“世界公民”优先，抱歉，是“某地的公民”与“无处之地的公民”，不是吗？我的意思是，那是特蕾莎·梅演讲中的内容。是的，我的意思是，因为那是一个有趣的演讲，因为现在这可能是我们之间的区别。当我听到那个演讲时，我的意思是，我是世界上唯一会承认这一点的人。当然是唯一一个做历史播客的人。我想，是的，太棒了。
I completely agree with that. Sod the citizens of the world. But, of course, most people who are historians who are kind of part of the literary world do see themselves as citizens of the world. They see the local as parochial well or as well as i'm constantly reading as xenophobic or as you know as um as nationalistic but i mean to go back to to your your your fantastic article about the the roots of all this in kind of early 18th century politics um the wigs as a marker of their their kind of progressive identity kind of scorn tory roast beef eating patriots like yourself dominic um and dr johnson well yes to to to a degree um and they identify
我完全同意这一点。去他的世界公民。但是，当然，大多数作为历史学家、作为文学界一部分的人，确实将自己视为世界公民。他们将局部视为狭隘，或者正如我经常读到的，视为仇外，或者视为民族主义。但我的意思是，回到你关于这一切根源于18世纪早期政治的精彩文章，辉格党人作为他们进步身份的标志，嘲笑像你这样的托里党烤牛肉爱国者，多米尼克，还有约翰逊博士。嗯，是的，在某种程度上。而且他们认同
with kind of french ideals so i mean all the way through the napoleonic wars you've got you know the holland house aptly named yeah they're all happily named lord holland and and so on they're all kind of you know byron is writing poems lamenting the fall of napoleon and and so on there's a kind of identification pain and yeah a sense that um that kind of uh british toryism is is not just um parochial but but kind of you know turpitudinous that it's xenophobic that that and and therefore to be properly moral you have to identify with um with the ideals of and and the cultures of places beyond the shores of of britain and i think that's that's always been a huge trend. And it's always particularly appealed to intellectuals and writers and poets.
法国的理想。所以，我的意思是，在整个拿破仑战争期间，你有，你知道，荷兰之家（Holland House），名字起得很贴切，是的，他们都起得很贴切，霍兰勋爵等等，他们都是，你知道，拜伦在写诗哀叹拿破仑的倒台等等。有一种认同感，痛苦，以及一种感觉，即那种英国托里主义不仅是狭隘的，而且是卑劣的，它是仇外的，因此要成为真正有道德的人，你必须认同英国海岸之外的地方的理想和文化。我认为这一直是一个巨大的趋势。而且它总是特别吸引知识分子、作家和诗人。
So Shelley and Byron are absolutely, this is absolutely what they are articulating. And I guess that today is no different, that by and large, that's, you know, I mean, that's the metropolitan liberal elites. It is. I remember, Tom, I remember being at Oxford. But Holland House is heaving, you know, in the Regency period,
所以雪莱和拜伦绝对是这样，这绝对是他们正在阐述的内容。我想今天也没有什么不同，总的来说，那就是，你知道，我的意思是，那是大都市的自由派精英。确实是。我记得，汤姆，我记得在牛津。但荷兰之家在摄政时期是熙熙攘攘的，你知道，
is heaving with metropolitan liberal elites, the equivalent of. I was about to say, I remember being at Oxford in the 1990s and hearing for the first time, so England were playing a World Cup qualifier or something, football, and hearing for the first time other students saying, how can you support England? Anyone but England. How can you support england you know anyone but england your own country and i was utterly dumbfounded because it was the first time i'd encountered this having sort of grown up and you know in the heart in a hobbit hole as you
挤满了大都市的自由派精英，相当于……我正要说，我记得在20世纪90年代在牛津，第一次听到，当时英格兰正在踢世界杯预选赛之类的足球比赛，第一次听到其他学生说，你怎么能支持英格兰？除了英格兰队，谁都行。你怎么能支持英格兰，你知道，除了英格兰队，谁都行，你自己的国家。我完全惊呆了，因为这是我第一次遇到这种情况，在某种程度上，我是在一个霍比特洞里长大的，正如你
know yeah in my hobbit hole and um yeah surrounded by the ghosts of nelson and toby john and all exactly so i couldn't believe that there would be people who were clearly english who who would not support their own and they said it wasn't just the anyone butting and thing it was also they didn't agree with the principle of supporting your national team at all no matter who you were if you were burkina faso they wouldn't agree with supporting yeah your own team because they thought that was nationalistic. In which case, why were they watching football? I mean, isn't the whole point of... They were trying to dissuade other people from watching it. They just thought the idea was national football.
所知，是的，在我的霍比特洞里，被纳尔逊和托比·约翰的幽灵所包围，等等。完全正确，所以我无法相信会有明明是英国人却不支持自己国家队的人。他们说这不仅仅是“除了英格兰队谁都行”的问题，他们甚至根本不同意支持国家队的原则，无论你是谁，如果你是布基纳法索人，他们也不会同意支持你自己的球队，因为他们认为那是民族主义。那样的话，他们为什么要看足球？我的意思是，足球的意义不就是……他们试图劝阻其他人观看。他们只是认为国家足球这个概念本身就是……
That's what people always say about football is that it's tribal, don't they? I mean, we saw that with the whole debate over the Super League is that the essence of the argument, which I thought was really interesting and how rapidly everybody agreed with it, was that football clubs should be local. They shouldn't be the property of global supporters,
人们总是这样评价足球，说它是部落主义的，不是吗？我的意思是，我们在关于欧洲超级联赛的整个辩论中看到了这一点，争论的本质——我认为这非常有趣，而且大家达成共识的速度之快——是足球俱乐部应该是地方性的。它们不应该是全球支持者的财产，
that really it's rooted in the local communities. And suddenly everyone was becoming kind of Tory in the 18th century sense. I think what's quite interesting is that there were some people, their voices were completely drowned out in the end, but particularly in America, there were people, for example, who are New Yorker writers and things, who are interested in soccer because it's, you know, it's seen in America as actually a bit more progressive
它们真正扎根于当地社区。突然间，每个人都变得像18世纪意义上的托里党人了。我认为非常有趣的是，有一些人，他们的声音最终被完全淹没了，但特别是在美国，有一些人，例如《纽约客》的撰稿人等等，他们对足球感兴趣，因为在他们看来，在美国，这实际上比支持美式足球或棒球更进步。
than supporting American football or baseball. And they liked the idea of the or baseball and and they were they liked the idea of the super league and they're kind of quite woke people and it's precisely that reason because it's they thought the idea of of the clubs being lifted from the communities and becoming national global things well i mean it's part of that universalism but also it shows they liked that but also it shows that there is a kind of little conservative within within everyone that if well isn't it said that you if there's certain things that when they get threatened suddenly oh we've got to defend this we can't have this exactly so exactly um let's have a quick question um from alex shiphorst so
他们喜欢超级联赛的想法，他们是相当“觉醒”（woke）的人，原因正是因为他们认为俱乐部从社区中被剥离并成为国家性、全球性事物的想法……嗯，我的意思是，这是那种普遍主义的一部分，但也表明他们喜欢这一点，同时也表明每个人内心深处都有一个小小的保守派。如果某些事情受到威胁，突然间，哦，我们必须捍卫这一点，我们不能这样。完全正确，嗯，让我们问一个简短的问题，来自亚历克斯·希普霍斯特，所以
he asks about generational he's he asks how much culture wars are generational now you saw that actually with the super league is a nice link to that because the Super League was supposedly set up for younger supporters who are more likely to be not so tribal and not so local. And also not to be able to cope with 90-minute games. Well, yeah. Which obviously is a cricket fan.
他问关于代际的问题。他问文化战争现在在多大程度上是代际的。你实际上在超级联赛中看到了这一点，这是一个很好的联系，因为超级联赛据说是为年轻支持者设立的，他们不太可能那么部落化，也不太可能那么本土化。而且也无法忍受90分钟的比赛。嗯，是的。作为一个板球迷，我显然……
I was a cricket fan. I was very worried about that. Yes. Yeah, well, of course. But, of course, the man who was claiming that, Florentino Perez, is about 138, so I'm sure he knows the... He's got his finger on the pulse of youth.
我是一个板球迷。我对此非常担心。是的。嗯，当然。但是，当然，那个声称这一点的人，弗洛伦蒂诺·佩雷斯，大约138岁了，所以我敢肯定他知道……他掌握着年轻人的脉搏。
Anyway, Alex Shipwell says he's thinking about the 1968 protests in France, which do have, I think, a culture war element to them, the protests against de Gaulle. And he says he's thinking about hippies, and he's thinking about arguments today about LGBTQ rights, veganism, et cetera, etism etc etc so do you think there's a generational i do how how yeah i completely do but and is and is that normal though in a culture war i think so right um so what you get i guess is the standard is you get a
无论如何，亚历克斯·希普韦尔说他在思考1968年法国的抗议活动，我认为这些活动确实有文化战争的成分，即反对戴高乐的抗议。他说他在思考嬉皮士，他在思考今天关于LGBTQ权利、纯素食主义等的争论。所以你认为有代际差异吗？我有，怎么……是的，我完全有。但这在文化战争中正常吗？我想是的，对吧。所以你得到的是，我猜标准情况是，你得到一个
a very um progressive ultra what you would say ultra christian younger generation and an older less christian um more orthodox more more conservative one is that right that's how you see the dynamic always work i think the dynamic has always been since the 12th century that that these kind of um impulses to purify the whole of Christendom, the world, this kind of mission to improve everybody. Initially, of course, absolutely couched in overtly Christian terms. In the 12th century, this leads to the setting up of universities. Universities are basically founded to train people who can provide the kind of moral and legal frameworks that can then govern now yeah and so what what then happens is that you get young people going there studying then going out
非常进步的、超……你会怎么说，超基督教的年轻一代，以及一个年长的、不那么基督教的、更正统、更保守的一代。是这样吗？这就是你看到的动态运作方式吗？我认为自12世纪以来，这种动态一直存在，即这些净化整个基督教世界、整个世界的冲动，这种改善每个人的使命。最初，当然，完全是以公开的基督教术语表达的。在12世纪，这导致了大学的建立。大学基本上是为了培养能够提供道德和法律框架的人，从而治理……现在，是的，所以接下来发生的是，你让年轻人去那里学习，然后出去
to work as priests or clerics or whatever and coming up against people again what the hell are you talking about i mean that's essentially what the albigensian crusade is the albigensian crusade is a targeting of the left behind of deplorables of people who are not up to speed oh my god with um so this is the sort of anti-racism yes sort of uh training people yes of the of the medieval period yes the albigensian crusade is a kind of very very brutal you know it's it's like the student coming back and and shouting at the father for using the wrong words um on a kind of very, very militant scale. There's a sense in which the Protestant Reformation
作为牧师或神职人员工作，然后再次遇到人们说“你到底在说什么”。我的意思是，这本质上就是阿尔比派十字军东征。阿尔比派十字军东征是针对那些被遗弃的、可怜的人，那些跟不上节奏的人。哦，我的天哪，用……所以这就是所谓的反种族主义，是的，某种……培训人们，是的，中世纪时期的。是的，阿尔比派十字军东征是一种非常、非常残酷的……你知道，这就像学生回来对父亲大喊大叫，因为他用了错误的词汇……在一种非常、非常激进的规模上。有一种感觉，新教改革
is the same in the French Revolution. And I think that you see exactly the same, that it's the universities, the role of the universities has always been to kind of educate and articulate progressive orthodoxies in a kind of radical new way and inevitably because it's it's in the universities that train the teachers who go out into the schools who then teach the young who then go through the the educational system who then become the teachers themselves and so
也是一样的，法国大革命也是。我认为你看到了完全一样的情况，即大学，大学的作用一直是以一种激进的新方式教育和阐述进步的正统观念，而且不可避免地，因为正是大学培养了进入学校的教师，他们随后教导年轻人，年轻人随后通过教育系统，然后他们自己成为教师，所以
it percolates outwards and outwards and outwards and so every generation you will find i mean i you know i used to think of myself as progressive, but now that I've got children, I know I'm not really progressive. Sorry, I shouldn't laugh. I know, I know, I know. But also perhaps it's also because as you get older, you regard as normal things that you had in your youth, and therefore you don't want them to change.
它向外渗透，一层又一层。所以每一代人你都会发现，我的意思是，你知道，我过去认为自己是进步的，但现在我有孩子了，我知道我并不是真正的进步派。抱歉，我不该笑。我知道，我知道，我知道。但也可能因为当你变老时，你会把你年轻时拥有的东西视为正常，因此你不希望它们改变。
So I think that's also a part of it. I don't want to incriminate you on the podcast but i think you were one of the first people i'd ever met who said to me it was just after the iraq war or thereabouts and you said um you really liked tony blair because he made britain look strong well he made he made he made he made he made britain i thought he made britain look good in a kind of bicycle-riding, aggressive... That's not what you said at the time. You used the word strong.
所以我认为这也是其中的一部分。我不想在播客上让你自证其罪，但我认为你是第一个对我说的人，那是在伊拉克战争之后或前后，你说你真的很喜欢托尼·布莱尔，因为他让英国看起来很强大。嗯，他让……他让……他让……他让英国……我以为他让英国看起来很好，以一种骑自行车的、咄咄逼人的方式……那不是你当时说的话。你用了“强大”这个词。
The first person I'd met in the sort of literary world who used the word strong approvingly of a political leader. But there's a kind of muscular quality. There was a muscular quality to it. Yeah, no, no, there was muscular Christianity. Yeah, a kind of self-assurance and a sense of purpose, which I must say I was still slightly wistful for. Well, now that I've got you cancelled, I wanted to...
我是第一个在文学界遇到用“强大”这个词来赞美政治领袖的人。但有一种肌肉感。有一种肌肉感。是的，不，不，有“肌肉基督教”。是的，一种自信和目标感，我必须说我仍然有点怀念。好吧，既然我已经让你被取消了，我想……
You asked about which one you were going to say. I've never concealed my admiration for... No, you haven't. You haven't, to be fair. You were waxing lyrical about him in our Prime Ministerial World Cup. So you were talking about universities, and I think that's a really good point, and it brings up Paul duncan's question so paul duncan asked the question i basically want the answer to because i want to i he says how a culture war is worn i need to know because i want i will not rest until there's a statue of field marshal lord roberts in every market town in
你问过你会说哪一个。我从未掩饰过我对……不，你没有。说实话，你没有。你在我们的首相世界杯中对他赞不绝口。所以你在谈论大学，我认为这是一个非常好的观点，它引出了保罗·邓肯的问题。所以保罗·邓肯问了一个我基本上想要答案的问题，因为我想……他说，文化战争是如何赢得的？我需要知道，因为我不会休息，直到英格兰的每个集镇都有罗伯茨元帅的雕像。
england but um paul duncan says if you're trying to win a culture war, and it's a key question, are you better off trying to change people's minds or to have your position enforced by the power structures of your time? And before you give your answer, Tom, I was thinking about the Reformation. I mean, the Reformation in England, the English Reformation, was by and large, I would say, pretty unpopular.
但是，嗯，保罗·邓肯说，如果你试图赢得一场文化战争，这是一个关键问题，你是最好尝试改变人们的想法，还是让你的立场由你那个时代的权力结构来强制执行？在给你答案之前，汤姆，我在想宗教改革。我的意思是，英国的宗教改革，英国宗教改革，总的来说，我会说，相当不受欢迎。
I mean, you've got the Pilgrimage of Grace. You have a series of risings, prayer book risings, and all these kinds of things. was by and large i would say pretty unpopular i mean you've got the pilgrimage of grace you have a series of risings from prayer book risings and all these kinds of things and the reformation it seems to me wins because it's backed from the top or at least sort of very you know with a bit of ambiguity but it's got them the states behind it but also because england is a very young country and people forget quickly and by the time Mary tries to turn back the clock she's a culture warrior of a very different kind because she's a kind of reactionary culture warrior
我的意思是，你有“恩典朝圣”。你有一系列的起义，祈祷书起义，所有这些东西。总的来说，我会说相当不受欢迎。我的意思是，你有“恩典朝圣”，你有一系列的起义，从祈祷书起义到所有这些东西。在我看来，宗教改革之所以获胜，是因为它得到了高层的支持，或者至少是……你知道，带有一点模糊性，但它有国家在背后支持。而且也因为英格兰是一个非常年轻的国家，人们遗忘得很快。当玛丽试图扭转时钟时，她是一个非常不同类型的文化战士，因为她是一个反动的文化战士。
I suppose you'd say or at least I'd say a lot of the people who remember Catholic England are dead and younger people have grown up knowing only Protestant England so to some extent it's just a question of outlasting your opponents and I guess
我想你会这么说，或者至少我会说，许多记得天主教英格兰的人已经死了，年轻人长大后只知道新教英格兰。所以在某种程度上，这只是一个比你的对手活得更久的问题，我猜
converting the young which is why I wanted to ask you about universities so do you think that is the way that you win a culture war through schools and universities or is it all kind of control of the state you know if Boris Johnson is listening and he wants to win his culture war can he win without universities I suppose is what i'm saying i think the universities matter more uh and that's kind of the grampskin idea that you affect change through culture and i would say that the most dramatic illustration of that i mean almost in the in the whole of history actually is the the um evolution of attitudes to homosexuality over certainly my lifetime um you know it a few years before i was born it was illegal now essentially it's illegal not to support it and you know my again my my
转化年轻人，这就是为什么我想问你关于大学的问题。所以你认为这就是赢得文化战争的方式吗？通过学校和大学，还是完全取决于对国家的控制？你知道，如果鲍里斯·约翰逊在听，他想赢得他的文化战争，他能不通过大学就获胜吗？我想这就是我想说的。我认为大学更重要，这就是葛兰西的思想，即你通过文化来影响变革。我会说，这方面最戏剧性的例证——我的意思是，实际上几乎在整个历史中——就是在我有生之年，人们对同性恋态度的演变。你知道，在我出生前几年，它是非法的，现在基本上不支持它就是非法的。而且，你知道，我的……我的
children i think would would find it kind of incomprehensible to imagine you know that living in a world where it was regarded as as as criminal um and that's obviously um i think that that's a kind of classic example of where the change of of public attitudes i think that was much more important than kind of individual politicians stepping in and oh absolutely i completely i think isn't it aren't things like that and also anti-racism um they're driven by sport they're driven by fashion and culture far more than anything any yeah but also i think but also i think uh accepting the essential justice of a cause that once once once once once something becomes kind of you know attains a critical mass then it becomes very very difficult i think to oppose it and that's kind of, you know, attains a critical mass, then it becomes very, very difficult, I think, to oppose it. And that's kind of what happens with the Reformation.
孩子们，我想，会觉得生活在一个被视为犯罪的世界里是不可理解的。这显然是……我认为这是一个经典的例子，说明公众态度的改变比个别政客介入要重要得多。哦，绝对，我完全同意。难道不是吗？像这样的事情，还有反种族主义，它们更多地是由体育、时尚和文化驱动的，而不是其他任何东西。是的，但我也认为……但我也认为，接受一个事业的基本正义性，一旦某件事达到临界质量，那么反对它就变得非常、非常困难。这就是宗教改革发生的情况。
It's what happens with the Christianization of the Roman world, that something can be quite kind of new and shocking to people in the initial onset of this perspective. But once it beds down, it just becomes the kind of standard very very but it also is about you want to you know people don't want to be viewed as eccentrics do they by and large um people people also successful talented people or people who dream of being successful they don't want to go they don't want to espouse views that will lead to their cancellation, as it were. So by definition, as people come up the ladder, they're more likely to go with the new orthodoxy rather than the old. But I think it's more than that. I think it's not even, oh, I better believe this
这就是罗马世界基督教化发生的情况，即某件事在最初出现时可能对人们来说相当新奇和令人震惊。但一旦它扎根，它就变成了标准。但这也关乎……你知道，人们不想被视为怪人，对吧？总的来说，人们，成功的、有才华的人，或者梦想成功的人，他们不想去……他们不想支持会导致他们被“取消”的观点。所以根据定义，当人们爬上阶梯时，他们更有可能追随新的正统观念，而不是旧的。但我认为不仅仅是这样。我认为甚至不是，“哦，我最好相信这一点，
or else I'll get burnt at the stake or thrown out of my university post or something. I think it's just people just think this is what I should think because of course I should think. Of course the Pope pope is is antichrist um of course gay marriage is absolutely to be celebrated i mean it's just what you think so here's a here's a counter example though a huge culture war which we haven't mentioned at all fought in the course of the 20th century communism's culture war on the old.
否则我会被烧死在火刑柱上，或者被赶出大学职位之类的。”我认为人们只是认为这就是我应该想的，因为当然我应该想。当然，教皇是敌基督，当然，同性恋婚姻绝对值得庆祝。我的意思是，这就是你的想法。所以，这是一个反例，一场巨大的文化战争，我们根本没有提到，发生在20世纪，共产主义对旧事物的文化战争。
So they have control of the universities. They have control of schools. I mean, they have control in a way that today's cultural wars couldn't dream of. But it doesn't work. And that's an interesting that lots of people, they preserve somehow the old orthodoxies or the old views, the the pole the poles and their catholicism for example so why do you think that cult that particular culture when they had all that apparatus of victory didn't work because it doesn't work economically does it so you think it was driven
所以他们控制了大学。他们控制了学校。我的意思是，他们控制的方式是今天的文化战争无法想象的。但它没有奏效。这是一个有趣的现象，很多人，他们以某种方式保留了旧的正统观念或旧的观点，例如波兰人和他们的天主教。所以你认为那场文化战争，当他们拥有所有那些胜利的机构时，为什么没有奏效？因为从经济上讲它行不通，不是吗？所以你认为它是被驱动的……
it was about the economics rather well we talked about that in the communism one that that that um it's it's an attempt to create heaven on earth that rubs up against the fact that it's not possible and that essentially you know a progress towards dictatorship perhaps is baked into the attempt to to impose it whereas let's end with this then go on no no no no no go on um so we talked about winning and losing does it have to be winning and losing, or can there be compromise? You see, what I see all the time is... Now, I'm now putting on my sort of popular newspaper hat. I see all the time sort of high-minded people moaning and saying, oh, they hate the confected culture war.
它是关于经济的。好吧，我们在共产主义那一期谈过，那是一种创造人间天堂的尝试，但与它是不可能的事实发生了冲突。本质上，你知道，向独裁的进步也许已经融入了强加它的尝试中。好吧，让我们以此结束吧。不，不，不，不，继续……所以我们谈到了输赢，它必须是输赢吗？还是可以妥协？你看，我一直看到的是……现在，我戴上我那种大众报纸的帽子。我一直看到那种高尚的人在抱怨，说，哦，他们讨厌被捏造的文化战争。
They hate all this. But then in the next paragraph, they then say how determined they are to win it and to crush their opponents and to strip museums of their problematic artifacts or whatever so it seems to me they patently clearly like the culture or they just want to win it can there be a compromise in some of these things do you think can societies find a way through or must it end with victory as it did with the christians for example and again in rome or indeed in the reform, mustered in with victory for one side or the other.
他们讨厌这一切。但在下一段，他们又说他们是多么决心赢得这场战争，粉碎他们的对手，从博物馆中清除他们的问题文物等等。所以在我看来，他们显然很喜欢文化战争，他们只是想赢。你认为在这些事情中可以有妥协吗？社会能找到出路吗？还是必须以胜利告终，就像基督徒在罗马那样，或者确实在宗教改革中那样，必须以一方或另一方的胜利告终？
Well, I mean, you've argued that the roots of our contemporary culture was lying in the 18th century in the Whigs against Tories. I mean, essentially, the lineaments of that argument is still present today. And there's a sense in which the parliamentary system the party system in britain evolves to create a dialogue between those two rival points of view so i would say yes absolutely because because in a sense i think that that you can see that there are the inheritors of of the whig and tory traditions of the 18th century are still going strong today and that in a sense the you know our parliamentary system exists to ensure that if not necessarily compromise then at least kind of you know that people can live alongside each other in the same country and have these arguments i know you disagree you want you want i want a total crushing defeat of the wigs. Okay, well, culture warring.
嗯，我的意思是，你已经论证了我们当代文化战争的根源在于18世纪的辉格党对抗托里党。我的意思是，本质上，那种争论的轮廓今天仍然存在。在某种程度上，英国的议会制度、政党制度演变出了在两种对立观点之间进行对话的机制。所以我说，是的，绝对。因为在某种程度上，我认为你可以看到，18世纪辉格党和托里党传统的继承者今天依然强劲，而且在某种程度上，你知道，我们的议会制度存在是为了确保，如果不是必然的妥协，至少是……你知道，人们可以在同一个国家里共存，并进行这些争论。我知道你不同意，你想要……我想要辉格党彻底的粉碎性失败。好吧，文化战争。
I used to like the Whigs, but I've now just taken against them completely. Okay, so this particular battle, I think, Tom, is over. You should retreat to lick your wounds. The war, of course. You have won. The war, of course, continues. As indeed does this podcast. So we will be back, Tom, next week with the French Revolution,
我过去喜欢辉格党，但我现在已经完全反对他们了。好吧，那么这场特定的战斗，我想，汤姆，已经结束了。你应该撤退去舔舐你的伤口。当然，战争还在继续。正如这个播客一样。所以我们下周会回来，汤姆，讨论法国大革命，
another very good culture war. But before that, we'll be back tom next week with the french revolution another very good culture war but before that we'll be back but before that before that we're back oh yes with with the podcast episode on a literal war the seven years war seven years war so certainly as well not a culture war then the french revolution definitely a culture war definitely and then food with uh pen vogler very entertaining food historian the food of course is a culture war of a different kind guillotines pies seven, Seven Years' War, we've got them all. And on that note, goodbye from me, and goodbye from me.
另一场非常好的文化战争。但在那之前，我们下周会回来讨论法国大革命，另一场非常好的文化战争。但在那之前，我们会回来……但在那之前，在那之前，我们回来了，哦，是的，带着关于一场真正战争的播客剧集，七年战争。七年战争，所以当然也是，那不是文化战争。法国大革命绝对是文化战争，绝对是。然后是关于食物，和佩恩·沃格勒一起，非常有趣的食物历史学家。食物当然是另一种文化战争，断头台、馅饼、七年战争，我们都有了。说到这里，我先告辞了，我也告辞了。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听奖励剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。